des voitures calcinées et près d'une
centaine d'hectares de cultures
détruites par le feu
voilà le bilan du violent incendie
survenu hier soir dans ce hameau de
champignelles pas moins d'une
soixantaine de sapeurs pompiers ont été
mobilisés pour venir à bout des flammes
une des 33 intervention opérée hier dans
le département avec plus de 300 soldats
du feu mobilisés
une situation exceptionnelle on a eu des
feux dans tout le département
si vous voulez nous au codis on a des
cartes qui nous montre les
disponibilités des engins on avait
l'ensemble du département quitté en
rouge
tous les centres de secours ont
participé à des interventions pour
essentiellement des feux des feux
extérieurs et à un moment donné on avait
plus un véhicule de type feu de forêt de
disponible dans une caserne en raison
des fortes chaleurs et de la sécheresse
beaucoup de ces feux sont liées
notamment à l'activité agricole et la
période des moissons
depuis le 1er juillet les sapeurs
pompiers sont intervenus sur 440 à 110
contre 250 sur la même période en 2018
dans ce contexte le service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
de l'yonne reste plus que jamais en
alerte la situation elle reste tendue
tant que n'aura pas plus on a une
situation des végétaux qui effectivement
est assez dégradé et qui doit justifier
du civisme et de la responsabilité de la
part de de nos concitoyens pour éviter
des départs de feu et et qu'ils prennent
les précautions minimales pour pour ne
pas générer des incendies qui pourraient
être catastrophiques
preuve que la chaleur et la sécheresse
continue de faire des ravages
une quarantaine de sapeurs-pompiers sont
intervenus cet après midi sur un feu de
chaume aux portes d'auxerre à 18 heures
sept hectares de cultures étaient déjà
partis en fumée